hello everyone we are continuing on a
both language design review meeting one
of our language completeness and
consistency series uh probably a bunch
of things heading into the version 13.2
release that we are currently very
actively working on
right so this is a really minor Point
um
and
um
but but it wasn't something we
explicitly discussed so I thought it was
worth bringing up so right now there's a
usage message which says you know
definition of string symbol prints as
the definition if symbol exists
um and it used to give an error message
if the symbol didn't exist but how do
you tell apart a string that's just a
literal string pattern and you know a
string that's a symbol that doesn't
exist so you know I want to just excise
that second usage and only leave in
place the you know you can give it a
symbol or a string pattern okay here's
the thing I think that's okay but I
think we gotta have something displayed
in the output here even if it's a blank
thing because it's just too weird it's
kind of like you know it's kind of like
the the the computation left the
building type thing um we didn't nothing
was left speaking of left the building I
just had a full out machine crash for no
clear reason so if anything was said to
me I missed it
oh okay sorry okay
um right although I would point out
that's not you know new Behavior right I
mean if you did definition of you know
so you're saying what's this behavior
before but the point was have a message
before so you're not like completely
confused about what the heck's going on
right about some kind of iconic thing
there that just says there's nothing
here
um maybe but right my point is it right
now if you if you did you know
definition of the symbol fubarity you
know you would get that same output
because there there are no definitions
attached to that symbol
I mean there's some argument that maybe
there's a front end thing where you
could have an indicator anytime an empty
string is returned
is that an empty string that came back
well no it's uh oh it it's it's just
foreign
so why is it not an empty list because
doesn't definition usually return no
list or something no definition formats
and then write it that sort of you know
uh it's it's sort of sharing the code
with save right so it's it's sort of
printing
how how things right and if you add some
attributes or whatnot
right it'll or options
right and it'll say right and then you
can copy and paste that into your
package file right and it'll work so so
maybe you could just have a comment that
like it returns a string with a comment
or formats with a comment that says like
no definitions or something like that
yeah that's that's that's possible right
I mean I don't think we'd want to do
that for every single right you know if
you give it multiple symbols right you
we wouldn't want to print one of those
for every single symbol but if the net
result is that there's nothing nothing
at all some little gray thing what's a
good indicator of nothing
I mean look if we had a little gray
indicator of nothing and it has a hover
effect that says no definitions found or
something then we're good
well it's just obscure what's going on
so we we need from graphic design some
kind of thing I think it's like a you
know a light gray box or something I
don't know what anybody got a better
idea for that
symbol for empty set
just
no freaking way other than for pun value
we have Jeremy and Billy here as well oh
really okay well maybe they have an
immediate idea I mean I'm not sure why
we'd want something graphical as opposed
to like uh I I think the comment of uh
the suggestion of a comment which saying
you know no definitions seems like
you know the obvious and understanding
this is just a formatting thing
I mean you're saying well you're never
gonna copy the thing that says no
definitions
well actually are you saying okay hold
on if I run this
and then I say input form of definition
of f
then you're going to see definition of f
I think
oh okay so an input form itself formats
that way
I'm gonna have to be careful about that
because we don't want something that's
an argument for the comment idea
because it means it would obviously
format that
mm-hmm
maybe the the iconographic thing we want
is a gray like empty comment with a
mouse over
it says no definitions and then when you
say
because I mean let's just try this I
mean if I say this
and now I say input form
oh that's really obscure
how many things input form how many
things have a
I'm that's really obscure
this presumably is definition
but this is obscure
right I mean it was an intentional
decision and maybe at one point you know
from well before I you know from the 80s
I think
um and
um
uh I'm trying to remember if there's
some reason for this that I'm not
immediately
remembering look I think it's pretty
it's pretty wedded to being taxed I mean
the input form seems like it there
really isn't any better alternative than
the comment I agree
I mean I have a bad feeling that this is
you know like save definitions and all
kinds of things like this there's all
kinds of programmatic things that use
this
mm-hmm
and maybe once when there are no
definitions to save it wants to have a
null string there
okay look your original question I don't
have an objection to it Yep this
question of what we should return
when there's nothing to return
I think it's a bit hostile to return
absolutely nothing here with no
indicator of any kind and I would
recommend that in standard form
the thing returned a great blob an input
form
maybe it should return a null comment
or no definition or something like that
um
how weird would it be if it just
returned to the symbol
that's not a good idea in my view
something's going to blow up if we do
that
right so so here's the question what
what about definition of empty list
um
even what does it do now or
well well I'm I'm pretty sure that uh
right because because you can give it a
list of symbols I I'm pretty sure
I have a bad feeling it's going to break
code if we if we change this input form
of you know
sorry hopefully not if it's a comment
but I mean but I was gonna say what is
two string of definition of blah blah
blah do because that's probably the
programmatic way people would access it
I'm sorry two string of definition of
you know empty Lister or whatever
right because well there are no symbols
for it to return there right if you if
you give it you know like plot you know
this the list uh you know plot plot 3D
then it would give you the attributes
and maybe and I guess options of plot
and plot three okay because it's read
protected so just just the attributes
right so if if you give it an empty list
then there's nothing for it to return to
you
yeah so
look I don't think this is deeply broken
it's probably been this way for 30
something years I think it's hostile to
not give any message I would recommend
in that case we at least give some kind
of blob that has a has a hover effect
all right we can look into that
um
okay
should we go on sure
open your package to a specific line
um
right so this is also I think we all
agree that it would be great if we could
open a package file to a specific line
what about a notebook what about a
notebook what about opening a notebook
to scroll to a section I would love that
uh notebook locate
so you open it and then you do a note
notebook locate so don't just no no book
locate can open as well
I didn't know that
okay
but yeah notebook locate given a cell
tag assuming of course that
cell tag is either unique or its first
appearance is the thing that you want to
scroll to then right yeah right so so
yeah and just so we're all on the same
page right we've always had the ability
to scroll to a specific cell I don't
think you I don't know that you can well
it's hard to sort of dictate the exact
part of the cell and I don't know if you
can scroll to a specific part of a cell
right but this is in the package editor
where it has lines exactly and so now
that we hit now that we actually have
line numbers in the package editor even
though we don't have the ability it
would John says it would be at least
right we can at least scroll to the cell
containing that line now if that one
cell is five pages long then yeah
but but we can get into the general
vicinity I mean but look the whole issue
with the new annotated uh parser type
thing will get us closer to being able
to have line number annotations and so
on
well I mean but the point with the point
is that we have line numbers in the
package editor right now and it would
not be insane to add the ability to you
know open and go to a particular line
number but we don't have a language spec
for doing so
okay but it will be a notebook open
and then it would be a that's that's the
that's the current proposal yes
and and and then an option to notebook
open why is The Notebook locate Kevin
you just told me notebook can go to a
cell tag why isn't there a stylized form
of cell tag that means a line number
nope
if sell tags can be anything including
you know any string including a string
that looks like why not okay why not do
this why not have this cell tag if the
cell tag is a list which can tell or
something let's say let's say that the
cell tag was
I'd say that was the cell tag
uh uh right now cell tax can I mean
actual cell types Can Only Be Strings
uh and not no I know but I'm saying use
the same what's the syntax in Notebook
well well open the help for Notebook
locate
John I didn't realize you were here
earlier and did you see that
unbelievably slow startup
um
kind of but uh the the way that your
screen sharing was working I
you know I I couldn't actually tell some
of what was going on
okay
um
oh come on we can do better than have a
version 10 screenshot here please guys
come on how many times do I have to say
the same thing for the documentation
team come on
well there's nobody from the
documentation team here so
um
okay but can somebody is there somebody
from project management here who can
take that message I got it I can send
that over
with some forcefulness please it's not
the first time I pointed this out can we
make sure we actually don't have these
anymore
okay so what you suggests that every
single version we find every single
screenshot I think we should try and
genericize the screenshots if this
didn't say Mathematica 10.0 we'd be okay
here
it's not great but we'd be okay
yeah and I guess I'd sell a Windows
screenshot right because you can see the
menu there yeah so but the top bar
doesn't look real is it I mean it looks
like some fake yeah the whole thing is
crazy okay yeah it's crazy
it shouldn't have a version number if it
didn't have a version number it would be
much better off
product well well I shouldn't even have
a product right this is geneticized
across products no of course yeah but
but but the issue is that for people who
are authoring under Windows uh that
information is in the I know so we have
to give them away something in
you know some wires thing or something
like that to that um
you know doesn't uh
um
um
uh by the way down on a live stream
points out for the previous topic that
we could look at this let's do
oh my
uh it's
yeah okay that doesn't seem relevant to
this okay that's nice though the
now you can also click the links and you
can follow the definitions
it's not super relevant this is a old
General utilities thing I mean and it
has you can see also it has this
automatic formatting too
why aren't we using this
why isn't this at least in wfr
it probably is
this is one of the more famous General
utilities functions I think
Ivory Association wfr okay
but
then
uh
what can we learn from it I mean famous
General utilities functions should be
you know
should be promoted
I don't know what what I mean well it's
it's I mean right it's a it's a typical
Tali hack that works in some cases if
you're using a front end and you know
can crash your front end if you have too
many definitions and doesn't work in a
terminal so also also we have a long
list of potentially promotable functions
that we you know need to go through but
we do not have a particularly efficient
process for doing that across the many
departments of the company
and it's not part I mean we've been
doing the low hanging stuff in ild this
is something else we can look at after
we finish the low hanging stuff
although we've also got lots of wfr
things to look at
all right well okay well I I I should
specify in particular it's wfr items but
many many things from General utilities
were placed in the wfr okay fine and
probably we did manage to pick the the
good fruit there okay let's go back to
notebook love Kate
okay file and tag
now you know this will be perfectly
civilized if we say file and then paren
and then line number Arrow 56. and and
just do whatever magic you need to do I
mean if you consider it a tag you
consider it a tag or you pass it out as
something different inside notebook
locate
John
and that's awesome
sorry you were saying anything I was
just asking would the would this syntax
also work in the notebook open I mean I
I don't recall the Syntax for Notebook
open notebook open does not support uh
cell tag mechanism okay which is okay
this is okay because I mean I don't
think I didn't remember notebook locate
did this but that seems like the right
place to put it I mean honestly this is
going to be part of bigger chains of of
tooling I don't think it's going to be a
raw thing people say oh I'm going to
open on line 56 they're gonna it's gonna
be part of some debugger tooling or
whatever else
right guys
uh well that's the most obvious
application but I could certainly
imagine people wanting to have their own
little right but
this since we've got a mechanism for
opening out a line which is notebook
locate that's what we should use do you
object to this it seems like well so so
rather than I mean does it make sense
rather than a rule sort of thing to just
interpret a number as a line number
because
tags up to this point
have been absolutely I'd be fine with
that I'd be fine with it being just a
number
makes sense to me
okay the only thing what what happens in
a thing that is not line numbered so to
speak like an ordinary notebook uh well
it would be the same thing that would
happen if the tag can't be found
which is don't move which is that if the
document is open it doesn't scroll and
if it's not open then it gets opened and
stays at the top okay okay
I don't I don't have a problem with that
I I have a slight
preference for this but I I think I it's
okay I mean it you know it slightly
closes down an option if we ever wanted
cell tags to be General Expressions but
if we ever want to sell text we General
Expressions then every expression is
like but that could be a cell tag so you
know we're
we're closing down something one way or
the other yeah I mean we could have a
cell tag that is a rule as well so I
mean exactly yeah
if it's easy I think it's fine just be a
number
okay
okay documentation links you say I have
to be in a different um oh no it's
working for you okay I don't know why
it's not working in my build
um
right so you see the little I
I do okay right out but what happens if
I click it okay so great yeah it uh I
guess I
um I guess earlier versions I saw
weren't
grayed out
um so so maybe I I mean that looks a bit
too gray it it it's okay to have it be
light blue which I think would be good
but I would just have it make sure it's
light blue but not grayed
that makes sense well I I worry a bit
about it becoming too loud in early
versions it seems really I know I know I
know I know which is why it was grayed
down but the point is what I hadn't
realized is by graying it looks like
it's non-functional I see guys guys
could we try a light blue for example
there
design folk anybody here Billy's here
can you try that Billy yeah and it just
needs to not look gray I mean guys
Jeremy or Billy you know just tell me
what makes it look gray I suspect it's
mixed with gray not that it's a well I
don't even know I don't know what I'm
talking about but that do you agree that
that looks grayed out or not
yeah it looks like it has opacity almost
and it might I'm not sure it is the same
it is the same art that's used in the
top line of information output
um because that was convenient for me to
grab so question mark plot you know it's
the same eye that you get
from there
yeah but that's on a gray background I
understand yeah so this is just isn't
right the Hue is not right but and and
the other point I wanted to raise is if
you click on the pill menu
yep
then we have yet another icon there for
the same link
that's crazy
right so so maybe we want to standardize
on the eye
um
but does the eye want to come before or
after
right because it seems all crazy that we
have the button in two places also
well the reason it's in two places is
because this has a real message right if
you did like
to sign with two arguments you would not
get the little I but you would still
have the
the the pill menu link to take you to
the ref page yes
right okay so hold on hold on if I've
got science so if the I is there it
always does the same thing as the book
oh well that that was a bad that was a
stupid example because sign obviously
argax has a message page but
um right so what's a message just just
make up a message yeah just make up a
message
the message
you know do message of
um
right and now if you click on the pill
menu
by the way by the way in 2022 we should
be able to do better than dash dash
message text not found
come on guys
don't you think could we know hey hey
they weren't hyphens
that's a win
[Laughter]
foreign
oh gosh
I mean it's just like very very entrails
of the goat
well I think it is
did you ever see it if you see this
you're you know you're right I mean
right I mean the point the right the
point is if if you know if a user
actually sees this then either they have
a bug in their code or we have a bug in
ours right no right okay but the dash
dashes are just really entreally
okay all right okay so in the K in this
case it went to the ref page for sign
because it had no better place to go
but it would have gone to the specific
page if there had been a specific page
but if there had been a specific page
you would have also seen an i
the the production of that eye is
intelligent it no you know you only get
it if there's a specific message page
okay but the eye here is just going to
whatever it feels like
or not whatever it feels like but
whatever it's it's casting the net wider
yes
right
would it be better if um when so when
there's a a documentation page for the
specific message if it gave if the pill
menu gave two links so one for the
function page so we'll just say sign and
then one above it presumably for the
message yes
and then also the menu would be
different when the eye was present right
so uh you know that hopefully would sort
of solve that confusion where oh well
you know this menu is the same but
sometimes they get they own sometimes I
don't oh actually when I get the I there
there's an extra item in this menu
right and then we then we keep the book
icon for the the sign and we I don't
know why we would do that I think we
could use I for both of them
we we have multi-eye things I mean
multi-i well we don't tend to have
multiple eyes at the same time right I
mean here you're right I
so how do we feel about having multiple
eyes at the same time
I think it would be nice if the symbols
were different because though the icons
were different because they are they are
doing sort of subtly different things
I come for what and what
and for the function exactly yeah
um well okay so maybe but look if we're
using an eye here
okay so look at what I could see doing
is having a gray eye
at the against the name of the message
and having a book against the name of
the function
how would you feel about that because I
think the I here this is an i and that's
giving the message specific
documentation so we've got to have the
same thing here yep I agree with that
and then using the book for the for the
symbol fine people think that's okay
wait wait sorry for the I think I missed
something using the book when
okay so in this case here not in this
case in in the case in this case here we
would have a stack of two things it
would say uh whatever the message is
sponsorino info
um and and that would happen
about adding a new item yeah okay okay
yeah I like the eye and the book it also
um you know the the the documentation
symbol in the toolbar is a book as well
so
um
okay question the order of messages here
do we actually want do we want maybe the
the specific message and then copy
message name turn off this message and
then the thing for the function maybe
underneath that
if so there should be a delimiter yeah
there's also another item in this menu
occasionally for showing the stack there
is there isn't here because there's no
stack to show right but so that that
comes before it doesn't have a delimiter
yes
so okay
well I just uh I just realized the
possible issue
um right if we have a separate line for
the symbol then and we're only showing
the symbol there then when there's no I
we're never showing the
uh
uh the message tag the message name
well do we have a I mean when there's
yeah I mean we we're showing the message
name right there
um
this might be a dumb question but why is
the message name hidden in the message
cell because because Steven thought it
looked ugly and scary I mean I was
opposed to that I think most of the
people here were opposed to that I think
it's been a big win though I think it
makes things look less you know by the
time the thing is spewing
messages you know you kind of know
you're you're descending into the swamp
I think this has been quite successful
this pill thing but the issue is okay I
like the pill except every time I
actually care about the message right I
I have to click on the pill which is a
big thing okay question when is it only
when we haven't documented the message
that we would not have a an I'm an eye
item for the message
right that's the only case if the
message is there but it isn't documented
right right doesn't have a dedicated ref
page or a general message page right
because messages can be attached to
General why don't we just make a generic
page that says this message doesn't have
a specific piece of documentation and
then put the thing up here with its eye
menu and oh well sorry if you clicked on
it well we misled you a bit
feel sub-optimal I mean yeah the the
including both the you know the the
documentation from the message and then
documentation for the function name I I
think we were sort of pleased with that
except we hit the snag that then you
don't always see the message name and so
I feel like solving that would be a
better route well maybe we should just
write the message name here
and if it is if it's not if it doesn't
have an icon next to it it just means
that's the message name and there's
nothing to click
or is it too weird to have a menu where
something can't be clicked on it is
weird
unless we had like a delimiter that you
know that somehow indicated that this is
the title of the menu
um these are the eyes
I think this one is nice that first one
doesn't look great out to me
any further objections
can I ask why is I
for message and book is for symbol given
that I also shows up in the symbol
autocomplete
that's a reasonable question
for the design folks I'll need a hover
State too and the number two seemed like
a reasonable hover state
yeah that works out but now we're
raising the possibility that there'll be
a book there instead of an eye
thank you
which would probably work
comments from other people about that
Ian's point is not bad that this
will like type start typing a symbol
yeah I know I know I know I know I know
it does I mean it's
I mean I think we should probably solve
it in the other places as well for
example like in the toolbar we use you
know a book for documentation and I
think in there are places in Cloud as
well
um and then obviously the eye is used
elsewhere we should probably I mean
there's not I don't think there's a
reason to have both we should probably
you know change all of those instances
well except that in some cases the book
indicates go to the root guide page
whereas the I is more drilled down yeah
and and the toolbar is a bit different
because the toolbar is a search
which is basically going to the root
with at the moment it's just opening the
root guide page
um
now in a perfect world you might want to
do a selection here and then you press
that button and it would automatically
search for that selection that would be
nice
that might I can't remember if that
works and that's what happens now yeah
oh I didn't know that maybe that means
I'm going to keep the toolbar open
uh is that any different from just
selecting it and hitting shift command F
like a sensible human being
okay so let's try this let's see if I
hit that
what do you know it actually worked good
stuff
okay Billy has the book version of this
which doesn't look bad well I guess
okay listen it seems like this requires
some thought and it seems like this is a
Noah type problem and I don't think I
think
uh
you know so this problem I mean look the
choices are
I mean what fraction of messages don't
have a page
I don't know
can I just say also I was thinking if
that doesn't necessarily have to be just
an action menu menu right we could we
could we could attach a cell there
instead and so we could put a heading
that's you know then we have more leeway
in terms of design right so we could put
a little header that's that's actually
the you know the the message name and
then we can put the options underneath
yeah except we don't want to repeat the
message name
my point is just that we we don't have
to we're not stuck to this format we
could use another cell and and therefore
have a bit more freedom as to what we
you know how we decorated what we put in
there
right well it could right it could say
like go to go to message page go to
symbol page or go to message page go to
name of symbol
um
instead of you know have repeating the
message name
yeah exactly well so
you have to have the message name at the
top and then it would say
message documentation
or go to message documentation
and then it would say
right and at the very bottom we could
have you know go to
documentation for well the problem it
could simply say sign and have a little
I next to it
but then what are we going to do with
the with the header which has the
message name what are we going to do
with the stack Trace then
is that that's okay that can go below
the the header I suppose
right it would be the header still show
stack Trace then
um
message documentation or something or
message what were we calling it message
what are we calling that
um I think I'm not sure we have a name
for it I mean we we can we
conventionally call them message pages
but that's probably not right that's
right but we could have we could go
um we could instead uh we could say
something like help for this message
no documentation for this message but
this message seems reasonable
all right try mocking it up let's see
where that goes it seems Seems like a
decent Direction
well they all right they said the
preparation cells
right so this was sent to me as
something you want to discuss in here
and I don't understand what problem
you're trying to solve because from my
point of view as the problem has been
described to me is
you create a cell that creates an
iconize and then you
you know copy and paste that or just use
shift command I understand yeah I
understand your point okay let me
explain the use case okay
okay
I have a notebook
it
contains some long-running code
okay
um
but I want to be able to run this
notebook
without re-running the long-running code
and the way I can do that is that I took
the answer from the long-running code
and I iconized that and I stuck it right
in The Notebook
but the long-running code is still in
the notebook I I just want it to not be
something that I get run that gets run
if I just press command a come on you
know shift enter
what I want another way of doing it
would be you know like the way I usually
do this is that I just have it so that
you know if you run all the cells that
includes running cells that like create
MX files but then the cells that load
the MX files or initialization cells so
the distinction is is instead just are
you running everything or are you
running just initialization but still
with that workflow there are cases where
you'd like to do with iconize but you
can't I don't know what possible design
would let you do it with iconized but
but you can't because it would have to
run the long computation and then insert
the iconized result into the
initialization cell
which right yeah I don't know how that
would work
do people understand this this you know
the workflow issue
yeah yes no maybe right so so there's
only in right from my point of view the
only possible issue is with command a
shift enter right because you're right
that oh yeah that that data equals my
hard-earned data could be an
initialization cell and then you know I
normally just start evaluating and and
the initializations go and then when I
want to update it I you know yeah if
reevaluate my iconize the problem is
what you really want is something I mean
look another thing I've done is just
making a non-evaluatable cell
I think that kind of defeats the point
though because I mean the use case I
think is is you want a notebook that you
can distribute where you can tell
someone just run the whole notebook from
beginning to end and it would do what
you want but while you're working on it
you want it so that you have cached
results
right and making non-evaluating cells
doesn't help that because if someone
actually runs it from beginning to end
it won't work
well yeah but but actually I think the
more common case is you want that person
to get the cash result you just want the
original code to be there in case you
need to rerun it or they need to rerun
it
so I have a very rough sketch of of what
might work
um can I share for a second thanks
um right by which point I think you know
just toggle comment is the solution
right it took well ordinarily run and
then if the user no it's horrible I've
done that many times that I it's really
it it just is so freaking ugly
particularly if it's a multi-cell input
that's multiple cells to create the
output oh gosh
and then it's commented it's just ugly
and really bad okay
okay so so the idea here is that you've
run something and it's taken long to
compute and because it's taking long to
compute a little sort of Icon has popped
up when the output is is you know is
written
um and then if you click on that
um it'll offer to kind of you know burn
that that data in
um and you know if we can work out what
the symbol you might want to be you know
the assignment is that then great we can
populate the simple Fields whatever
um and then if you hit OK then it kind
of you know it deactivates
that input cell and then underneath it
shows a thing that will actually be
evaluated which is just you know data
equals whatever yeah the data equals it
just needs in in the default case
there's no need for data equals it can
just be
um it can just be that cell because
that's equivalent to the output line
having been generated well it depends if
you're wanting to restore if you if
you're sort of almost wanting to restore
like a kernel State then this is
useful if you're if you're if you're
doing things more with like percent then
oh it's a data equals there yeah yeah I
see I see I'm sorry I didn't notice that
it said debt equals
oh oh in the Empire yeah yeah
right
um so I mean this is like stress this is
not a proposal it's just an idea of what
a route we might want to go down
um but
uh it's kind of interesting I mean I
think that what do we think about the
possibility of that Auto
AutoCAD I think it's pretty nice I mean
I think the obvious place to put that
though will be in the cell gear menu
right you want it to kind of be
uh it took a long time yeah and also the
fact that it's next to the output label
seems like a natural place for it
because because it's sort of you know
applying very directly to that
yes Crystal you were going to say
something
well I was gonna ask so so how
let me see how do you run the uh how
would you get it out of this state
yeah and it would just get rid of this
and then reactivate this
okay is there a way though that because
I I like you know at least doing it with
like MX files there's this you know I
like how you can have the distinction
between run all cells and run
initialization cells that basically lets
you choose globally what do you want to
do
um I wonder if there'd be some way of
basically saying run this and and ignore
all of the pre-computed stuff versus run
this and you know use all the cached
stuff all right cool because I was going
to say right I mean if
and you know see I don't see how this
solves Steven's case of you know and and
a bunch of cells because then you'd have
to click however many X's to that's
another issue okay but in the case where
this is iconized where we say data
equals you know iconize range of 10
million or something
so you want me to do this okay
well it's still though no matter what
this is a fair bit easier than the whole
you know you compute the thing then you
run iconize the thing and you copy
iconize you know down into a new cell
like that's
yeah that's more work for sure
right but so if this thing
and by the way you could you could put
up one of those burn things whenever you
get an iconize as the result
sure yeah
um I don't really see the icon looks
really weird the icon seems like it's
putting things in a garbage can I mean
this is a very very rough scan no okay
no no matter
um okay but then in this case what we
say iconize here
if we say data equals iconized no that's
not going to work because data equals
iconize is exactly doing the wrong thing
because that has a stupid iconize in the
middle what you want is data equals the
actual iconized object so that the real
thing that comes out is just the innards
of the iconized object
see what I'm saying
I mean are we just talking about the
formatting of the thing in the gray box
no I'm talking about the fact that if I
say data equals iconize range of 10
million okay oh and
to the right thing
because what you want is the data to be
set to the you know the icon not the
original iconize input
Noah you get what I'm saying
uh sorry not quite so look look look if
you say data equals there
yeah now say data you know length of
data I think it'll work just fine
I don't think so I think there'll be one
no surely it'll be what oh yeah because
it evaluated to something right so head
of data is iconized or iconized object
oh okay okay okay I don't understand how
I canized objects disappear then but
okay
because they're in basically inside of
an interpretation box they format as
interpretation box yeah
yeah
okay
and that's not wrong because you want to
be able to pass iconize things around
you don't want them to evaluate and blow
up in your face
the only thing that blows them up is
shift down to evaluation
just
do that
yeah yeah I don't think I'd sort of
internalize that that's actually what
happens okay
right so the issue is
you got an iconized result
really what you're trying to do is
you're trying to refactor that code to
say data equals the result
which is kind of what you were doing
there also
humph
well actually does this not work if you
say data equals actually the way you've
done it there it would work because what
you're doing is you're somehow
parallel transporting so to speak data
from the input to the output the data
equals from the input to the output sure
right that he he'd have to
write read in the result from the output
cell not from percent
which maybe you'd need to do anyway but
right the point is that yeah
yeah that's right
so he's got to copy the output cell so
it says data equals whatever the
contents of the output cell were
um
I mean I'm wondering is the presumption
has been that the you know the front end
should pop something that sings and
dances and and rearranges uh but this
could be a kernel function that does
this
I mean it's something like iconize set
of data comma range of a million
which then produces
you know this kind of you know output
input you know this kind of memoized
input the results
how
well I mean I mean so remember John
remember and the original thing that
says iconize set whatever it is right
well I I mean it would have a side
effect of read of you know
uh kind of rearranging the input that
produced it to do the right thing
but the point is and and you could then
do this you know with multiple
assignments in a given cell
um you know where they would just all
aggregate into one
you know output day inputs that uh
Replacements I I get it but what is the
workflow because in the when you rerun
you only want to use the memoized
replacement
right right and what I'm saying is that
uh uh this would essentially
uh construct
um probably uh a cell group
um that uh you know that would
redecorate the input cell to make it
inactive
uh and and provide an active
input cell
you know that would be you know uh that
would be sent by shift enter instead
so sort of like this then but sort of
constructed not through an interface but
programmatically exactly
sorry and and and and and you know the
way you have it constructed there it
looks like an attached cell I'm not
saying something that would be an
attached though this would be you know
an actual cell that would I see so this
is this would basically function like
cell print it's it's like cell Prints
but it also has some side effects on the
uh input cell that generated it
hmm
but it would always group with the
original input cell
and
then if you if you destroy it it
reactivates the original input cell
I'm not completely seeing how this would
work if you want to do you want to say
it more explicitly
um
um okay so uh
uh so okay here let me give a so I
haven't I'll confess that I haven't been
100 following but let me take a guess at
what you're I think you're suggesting
and then maybe that'll make some sense
to other people so you're saying so so
Noah has written there I can I set data
range of a million
and that will somehow write that
function function would
modify that input cell to make it
unevaluatable and produce a another
input cell beneath it which is
data equals you know an iconized thing
whose value is correct the the list one
to a million and they would be grouped
together
and there might be other graphical
things we would do too to make it clear
they're part of the same thing but they
were this is
not a bad idea
anyway
and then you know we don't have to
heuristically try to figure out well
which assignments belong to which
iconizations because they were specified
precisely
in the inputs
yeah I'm not sure if you have multiple
assignments in single input language I
don't think is the most important case
well well I mean actually that works
really well because we can then is
simply aggregate them together as a
compound expression
oh I see what you're saying now data one
equals blob semicolon data two equals
blob
minor technical question would this need
the enhanced metadata where we've talked
about in order for it to know which cell
to modify or
no because modifying the cell it's
evaluating it
so it's it would require a bit of
trickiness uh or if I shouldn't say
trickiness a bit of new functionality in
the front end where you know it could
recognize that uh you know I'm in a cell
group where
um I mean frankly it would work today if
the iconized thing
were allowed to be the first cell in the
cell group you know uh if we prepended
you know this iconized thing instead of
upending
um then it could work in today's
technology if we prefer to upend it it
would require a bit of new tech in the
front end but it wouldn't be that much
but you're saying if if okay
well I think it does need to be
pre-panded I think it's otherwise rather
obscure yeah but but I mean if it's
prepended we already have a way for the
first cell in the cell group to restyle
other cells in the same cell group
um this is nice this is a good idea this
is a good way to do it
yep very nice
all right and and of course one of the
things that would be in the style would
be evaluatable Arrow false
yeah so
yeah and then and then you would
evaluate it by blowing away the the cash
and recomputing yeah yeah
at which point when you blow away the
cash it would become evaluatable again
and then you click time and if you the
only thing that will be important is
that you'll be able to copy the cache so
but that shouldn't be a problem yeah I
can I can work with Noah to have a a you
know a better or even maybe even
functional prototype of the ideas this
is a cool idea
I like it okay let's shall I go back to
um
I have a question
why is this tied to iconize
right I mean in many cases you're right
it's because the output is large in in
very many common cases but it doesn't
have to be a large output
okay fat point I mean iconize also
avoids the possibility that outputs
contain formatting that is not parsable
like short shallow
[Music]
iconizes one case I agree with you that
I can imagine a situation in which you
have just the list three seven eighteen
and it took a really long time to
compute that
yeah I mean you know there could be you
know it could be like a memoized set
uh or I mean yeah I don't know that
quite criticize the name but you get the
idea no but I'm not sure if that quite
works because of the fact that the
iconize will sit in there
but in other words unless the icon is
meta unless the iconized is meta added
to the process
having iconize
you see what I'm saying having iconized
as part of the actual expression being
evaluated will not peel correctly
yeah well I mean uh you can handle that
with two functions you can handle that
with an option
um two functions
uh two functions might make sense
because uh you know if you have an
iconized set you might also want to name
the iconize
oh yeah good point
I think I can I set and just memo set or
whatever the heck it's called this seems
this seems very good very nice I had not
seen how to solve that
nice
all right let me let me just um keep
going for a bit here
forms involving characters that parse to
other symbols
right so for example if you type in you
know an alpha then it parses to the
character Alpha but if you type in the
character Pi it parses to the symbol uh
you know Capital right
um
right
so
um
and you know this is not just me being
uh you know hyper Vigilant this is
coming from an actual user bug report
that
uh oh my God
was the user Greek do you know
uh I don't think so they were they were
using pi you know they were trying to
use Pi blank in a pattern for I don't
know what reason and you know we're very
surprised by
didn't work of course they didn't
actually diagnose the problem but uh you
know it's it's all uh it's been a I mean
that's been obviously been there since
the mid 90s yep so right so it's not a
huge priority item but you know we
should decide what we want the behavior
to be and then you know we can what
would happen What happens if you say F
of Pi blank does that work or is it
yeah okay so and then that one goes to
pi squared does that work or does that
does that always go to so if I say F of
seven
yeah it works fine right
but they but but you can't do that with
uh you know the actual character pie
or or a lowercase pie right you could do
that with a capital Pi but not with the
lowercase pie
what do you mean do I mean if it paused
if if this thing here just pause to the
symbol you know pi
at a low level in the parser right yes
exactly so right so if if if if if you
agree with me that that that thing
should parse to pattern of you know
capital p i yeah
um blank bracket bracket
um then yes then it would just work uh
what's the reason to not do that
um
I mean it means that if you do it that
way I have no idea what happens if I do
this if I say hold
of of this pie
okay that that is capital Pi already so
what the heck is this one here
I I think it's just a bug in the plaza
right so
um if if we're all agree that it's just
a bug in the parser then we will treat
it that way and you know I right what I
don't know is how much effort would be
involved in fixing this bug
with Alexa
mm-hmm
but I don't think it's that horrifying
because these characters are not you
know just have to be careful in Alexa
right
so yeah all right um if yeah my opinion
was it's just a bug and it you know the
pie there should act like a pie anywhere
else
um the fact that it's behaving weirdly
is
unexpected yep
okay binding of pattern and alternatives
I strongly expect that that
documentation comment was added because
that's what I or somebody else thought
it did
okay
but
pattern symbols that appear only an
unused Clauses of alternatives are bound
to sequence but it isn't true
I mean I'd be very happy for them to
bind to something much weirder than
sequence
mm-hmm because if you use I mean this is
the quintessential undefined variable
yep
you know I'd be happy for it to bind to
some you know just like we've we've now
got terminated evaluation right
you know I'd be perfectly happy for it
to say unresolved pattern or something
it's a very Corner case like terminated
evaluation by the way can I see
terminated evaluation in an action
um oh well sort of
right actually like empty sequence
because I actually use it if I have
Alternatives like that I need to have a
sequence if the pattern doesn't bind
I do use such parcels
hold on we'll get to that in just a
second I'm wondering about this
Terminator evaluation thing okay so the
okay so it's just a note from then on
out yep
right and right you wanted a a so so
this is actually a question worth worth
uh raising
um they're turned in there turned out to
be sort of a technical issue with
um right you we wanted an expert struct
with the the thing that went bad in the
second argument yeah and there turned
out I mean
there's a technical issue of we don't
want to have to load the whole compiler
at startup just in order to receive that
message and which is obviously a
solvable problem but it wasn't solved in
this version can I make a suggestion
could we format this in pink
um I would rather not if this is not the
intended final form then I I would
rather not start adding but it's close
to the final form I just wanted it pink
in the same sense that you know
oh gosh that didn't work how do I get a
how do I get a negative Precision number
uh you need a DOT there right yeah
maybe I need the double Watching Me Oh
yes
okay that's what I mean I'd like to see
that
[Music]
well I guess we can
I know I think that would be a little
weird
um
I just think presenting it as just to be
happy
this is a result is the wrong thing I
think it needs to be like this one it
needs to be a little bit weirdified and
to have a mouse over as well that says
you know this was terminated because it
ran out of evaluation whatever
um
I just don't think it should look as
plain as it does there
is it possible that when it gets
returned that the front end line
breaking will
put the payload on a separate line from
the head
so what if it does I'm just thinking
that the you know pink the embroidery
stuff will look oh really weird in that
case
okay
that's a good point what is what does
the front end do
I mean isn't it just a frame what what
happens if I just say framed of um uh a
range of 200 comma background Arrow pink
it's okay I don't think it's that bad
I mean if it you know if it broke at the
end of a line beginning of a line it
knows what to do with things like that
it's just gonna leave it as a single a
single thing
all right anyway that's what I think we
should do but this just pinkify this
terminated evaluation does anybody
object to that idea as just an idea
independent of how difficult it is to do
well I mean
[Music]
um
I
I mean I think we could
I mean I don't like it but I'm not sure
I can give you a very strong reason why
I don't like it
um
but
[Music]
um
I just think it needs to say weirdness I
mean it needs to exude weirdness when
you get this
mm-hmm
um all right anyway that's my suggestion
if we don't have objections to it we
should try to do it but let's go back to
next issue about sequence of of nothing
wait a minute
so what was your point
our next point no next point
well my bag that I initially reported
was simply about that sequence
completely disappears from the hold
complete there well the I mean the
sequence doesn't disappear it's not
there it was never there
the point is that what sequence hold and
what's not
no it has nothing to do with sequence
hold
right so you're saying the sequence
disappeared because that sequence was
pseudo-evaluated away
it well my claim is that why was never
given any value and so it it yeah if you
want to call it sudo-evaluated away then
sure but okay if I do this if I go to
just uh what are we doing here
f
what the heck do I need to do here this
is well if I go to x here
yep
thank you
and oh I see if I go to x and I go to y
oh my God right it's like a more
interesting question is what right so in
that case
right
so I think only in the case and I think
that's just replace I'll sing while I
ended up with nothing and so I'm
returning sequence bracket bracket
um
yeah no I mean I'm sure it's a it's a
corner case in the code
um right and so then the question is do
we consistently want to bind every
single
um
you know Unbound you know very variable
that only appears in an unmatched
uh alternate you know unused case of
alternatives to sequence bracket bracket
and I'm not sure what the use case of
that is well Nick has a use case
apparently well he's he said he has a
use case he has not provided the use
case
when they have a
an alternative
usually like appropriately like if you
have a property can be a string or at
least with a string and arguments and I
can bind it with alternatives
and arguments would be a sequence name
team sequence if I don't provide my
property as a list
that's a use case very simple one that
makes absolutely no sense to me do you
want to be more explicit Nick
or I can show you yeah okay I can just
take it out
okay here you go
something like if I have some object
or a function that takes a property
like that and some arguments and you
want to use alternatives
to do this oh and property is a string
like I want to use this pattern and if I
provide this function
with a with just a property
I want arguments to be an actual
sequence yes but why do you care that
Arts is an actual sequence
that I mean I I I I I have written
patterns exactly like that a gazillion
times and I have never felt the need for
args to be a literal what do you
actually need is just for consistency
um ambiguity when it actually have a
code complete somewhere inside of it
maybe I want to preserve this type of
save this argument somewhere
I want to be explicit that those
arguments were an empty sequence
I I put some examples in chat wouldn't
the consistent thing
be its current behavior that's what
triple underscore does and what repeated
null does
[Music]
right right
foreign
you don't get hold complete of sequence
you just get hold complete
right
but the point is that they actually want
the sequence verbatim
and I can't even imagine
so in that right so in that particular
case right args would bam would bind to
absolutely right it would bind to the
literal zero length sequence that gets
inserted as no arguments now if if if if
you want to make a claim you use you
know blank blank rather than than maybe
but
you know then in that case right it
actually matches this pattern right if
you have an old blank sequence there
yeah make it double blank rather than
triple blank oh I see you have a list
versus not a list okay
um yeah so I guess it's unused either
way
um
um
well you don't even need a triple bike
you just need args blank but because in
one of them there's uh right in one of
them there's a list and and the other
there isn't
no I understand I understand it's not
going to conflict
but you don't need a triple blank right
you just just need you you don't need
don't need it but it doesn't change the
case he's making in this particular case
yes it does because much weirder to bind
args to a null sequence if if args is a
triple blank it's much less weird to
bind it to a null sequence if augs is a
single blank when do you ever see a
single blank bound to an L sequence I
see
yeah that is weird well you do see it
when it's bound to an unmatched part of
an alternatives
right like in that top case
right
how about this case
what's wrong with that yeah
oh it's a default why why it's not
always not a two but okay well because
it didn't match so I mean but but it's
got a default right so the question is
why did it move on to the or problem
because it does because he didn't give a
list right if he gave G of list
containing yes then you have to try it
yeah try it try it achieve the list with
just X
point is that whenever you have a
default binding like that that should
propagate to the right hand side
it never it never sees that
imagine it shouldn't find the default
it's right yeah it's just like but if
you have multiple down values and you
know the default has a side effect right
you don't want that firing
right
but you know this is the same thing in
both cases does the thing bind in that
first example does the thing bind to a
null sequence which is then crushed out
of existence or does it never bind
or does it never create which first
example are we talking about here one at
the top of the screen the one that was
the one that um before next started
sharing I think that the one that was
showing
something like
yeah why blank or whatever
yeah I don't see why it would ever have
gotten to the second
alternative right
that it doesn't bind anything
right it literally binds uh zero
arguments as opposed to the expression
sequence bracket bracket okay but change
that to not behold complete XY to just
be a y on the right hand side
well leave that line just make a new
line it's gonna be a sequence yeah yeah
it's going to be a sequence
right and it's going to be that case
because back in the day this gave a
memory fault
foreign
okay okay it was a case that wasn't
properly handled
right and and then right and you you see
right uh right I mean this is sort of
the same behavior of like if you delete
all the parts of an expression you get
sequence bracket bracket right you get
some if you literally end up with
nothing then the evaluator gives you
sequence bracket bracket yeah but but
you won't get sequence bracket brackets
and sort of any other case I mean
arguably now that we have things like
terminal evaluation
you know that's more the kind of thing
you should get in these Corner cases and
these cauterized Corner cases rather
than something that pretends like it's a
valid thing
because this is a corner case there's a
weird Corner case you should never see
and it's a bug basically
bug
well this isn't a bug the behavior isn't
a bug but the the using an Unbound thing
like in that line 46 using the Unbound y
on the right hand side is pretty much a
bug
I I'm not convinced of that how How
would
I mean what where exactly in the
evaluation process would that even get
noticed and then my claim is
that uh I think it's a feature
I think it's really nice to know which
branch of my pattern matched on the
right hand side and so I'll do things
like if list of Y is equal to empty list
then do something
yeah I I can see that that that's a
reasonable use case
so even though the matcha never saw it
even though it had no opinion
it wants to have a default opinion for
the sake of using it yes
I can tell you how I solved it in my
implementation of the patterns I
basically had like a different
version of alternatives
that had this Behavior
yeah but it's like binding all different
so he wants it instead of a magically
evaporating away he wants it to bind to
a literal sequence bracket bracket
which as as
Jeremy just pointed out right you can
just test if hold of Y is
you know hold bracket bracket as opposed
to if hold of Y is hold of you know
sequence bracket bracket I guess it
needs to be hold complete so it's well
okay Nick is claiming that his version
is more consistent
right and it's I don't think any of the
things we've said are use cases
is
what the heck is that match replaced
doing
I don't understand what your match
replace list is doing in the first
instance there
no and nothing was ending up with y's
and X's
well this is just text it just never
visited this thing so instead of not
much and if it's just left oh I see I
see I see it's returning okay that's a
different Behavior that's a completely
different Behavior that's a it didn't
meet it didn't I think that's a very
very weird behavior and I have to go in
one second
um
wow that's
basically because yeah I generate
matches
right a list of matches there
much pointing together
because it there are two ways of you can
you can match but each of them contains
only a single variable so if you do the
replacement Vol device on the right hand
side yeah I understand then then that
simply doesn't get replaced yeah I
understand that's also weird Behavior
I mean that's that's behavior that is
not good for a down value This is
complicated
right I mean I think we can all agree
that percent 48 is is a bug
let me see
oh my God removed of dollar variable of
one yeah that's a bug what the heck is
that
oh my gosh the problem or the problem is
you're using
uh no I see what the the pattern is
inside of an accept so you're using the
thing that's not supposed to match as as
the match which is just a bizarre right
I mean one could also argue this is
giggo because uh semantically I think
that makes no sense
um
by the way Ethan is commenting you need
except a blank question mark option Q
oh I see that that's an argument that
isn't an option
right oh I need to go I'm sorry
we need to continue this another time
okay
uh all right we had one more item I
think which um yeah we can wait till
next time there's no rush okay good
stuff thanks guys we'll have to come
back to this pattern matching thing what
a horrifying area
okay
see you later bye